what is going on everybody welcome to
the 10th Cavey tutorial video in this
video we're gonna be talking about the
screen manager so I've already talked
about this what the purpose of the
screen manager is in the last video so
we're just going to go ahead and hop
right on into it so to get the screen
manager we have to make another import
and this one's going to be from TV UI x
dot screen manager import screen manager
we're gonna also need screen and then
we're gonna import fade transition so
not only is it going to allow us to
change between screens there's a quite
well there's a handful of transitions
that you can use that just kind of makes
it look a little better as you
transition and it literally a transition
helps the user know that transition is
even occurring right but it's also it's
just more user friendly and it looks
better so anyway those are the things
that we need and now we're ready to
actually build our application luckily
or at least for this tutorial we can do
it pretty simply we're just going to
need a lot of classes that happen to
pass but anyways first we're gonna have
a class and we're gonna have a main
screen and main screen is going to
inherit from screen basically to use a
screen manager we need to import from
screen and inherit from screen rather
and then so main screen will pass then
we're gonna have class another screen
again it's going to inherit from screen
and again it's just gonna pass and then
we'll have class screen manage
management it's really easy to koi
when you're like doing tutorials or just
like trying to learn about something
it's really easy to make the function
named the same thing as what you're
working with either a module or exactly
this because generally they name their
things a pretty intuitive name as well
so you can get in all kinds of trouble
anyway screen manager don't do that so
this will be a screen management class
which we'll cover in just a moment and
then it's going to inherit from screen
manager which is here
you guessed it it's gonna pass okay so
we don't really need any logic at this
point simply because we are really just
doing like the visual and keavy kind of
stuff at this point so we don't actually
need to put any logic here but soon you
can imagine you might and that's
basically it
although we need to get rid of these
right here so presentation is not a
function it's just a variable so we're
going to go ahead and get rid of that
and now we're ready to move into our kv
file so we'll save that there and we'll
come over to our ki v file and I'm just
going to go ahead and delete everything
out of this main kv we don't really need
anything there and if ya I'm gonna
delete okay so now that we want to do is
we want to utilizes meet or fade
transition and later on you can actually
you might do something with it but
actually probably the main use of fade
transitions going to be in the key V
file anyways but so to do it import in
your ki V file it's really quite simple
but I guess it's it's kind of flipped
around
but anyway it's kind of I'll just show
you so we want to import what we want to
import fade transition and then from
where so key v UI x dot screen manager
dot fade transition okay and that's our
import that's really the only thing we
need to right there now we're gonna
reference first screen management and
basically talk about what screen
management is managing so first we have
screen management colon tab and first
we're going to reference transition
transition is you know like an element
of our screen manager okay so what we
inherited from to make our screen
management class their transition you
guessed it we're going to use the fade
transition then uh what are the screens
that we're managing will remain
judging main screen and we're gonna
manage another screen okay and later on
you might be able to add some stuff here
for now we'll just leave those actually
completely blank so now let's create our
main screen rules here and um again TV
files are not like spreadsheets Earths
spreadsheets style sheets um in the
sense that you know like you reference
say an ID so main screen is our you know
parent and then we've got this child you
know ID basically and then we can pass
some more things and actually reference
that ID and have a user scroll to that
ID and all that kind of stuff it's kind
it's basically the same thing here so
here we're gonna give it a name in the
name of main screen we're just gonna say
is main and that's basically it and then
we we want a budding here capital B for
button by the way we want a button tab
over we're gonna have a few elements
here and what this button is going to do
is on release which is a function of a
button here on release what do we want
to happen well app dot root
dot current so our app is basically this
right main app and then we're saying
basically dot root dot current for the
current screen that we're looking at and
we want to actually change that to other
if the button is going to be the on so
the main screen and it would be like hey
go to another page or go to these
settings or whatever basically this is
what controls what this button does so
we want it to head to other for another
page so the name of our say another
screen for the IDE like the ID anyways
the name is going to be other so that's
kind of how you reference them anyways
that's on release but we need a few
other things first of all we need some
text to let the user know what the heck
is about to happen well just look how
this actually next screen that's
probably the easiest and then finally
font size will just say 50 so it's nice
and clear and that's basically it with
the main screen and now we're going to
code the another screen I'm going to
just copy this paste this
instead of a main screen it is another
screen name is other when we release the
button on this screen we want to change
back to the main screen and then of
course this will say something about
going back home so we'll just say back
home okay easy enough and now we've got
basically all of our required you know
TV stuff and we've got our buttons we've
got our screen manager managing our
screens or screens are willing to change
the current screen to other and the way
that we're doing that is with a fade a
transition so I think we're ready to run
let's see if we have any errors so you
can run that our screen comes up short
off we have next screen we click on next
screen and we see it faded to this
screen here we'll click it again and we
go back home so we can see that this
basically worked the way that we at
least for now have intended obviously
the button is giant and we don't really
do anything else but we are able to go
back and forth between various screens
and then obviously as time goes on we
can add some information it's more you
know kind of gooey stuffs logic here and
then come into our actual TV file add
some more kind of graphics and
customization and maybe not make the
button take up the whole screen that
kind of stuff so we're gonna add stuff
there so I figured that most or the best
thing to do now would be show since in
the previous video we actually made an
application where we were drawing stuff
right why not just add that application
as if it was you know anything else so
we'll add that application will
basically come to the main screen we'll
hit this it'll come to our application
and then maybe there's a button that
heads us back home okay something simple
like that so that's what we're gonna
cover in the next video so stay tuned
for that if you guys have any questions
or comments on this video please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support subscriptions until next
time